welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we are hosting
webinars daily my name is Jeffrey de
Gotha
and today we were going to be talking
about Chrome Enterprise and keeping your
business safe in the cloud thank you for
joining me throughout our presentation
you can ask questions anytime on our
platform and we have Googler standing by
to answer them now let's get started
into the presentation so the title of
this presentation is keeping your
business safe and in the cloud and I
think you're here today because a lot of
businesses face challenges as they move
to the cloud and keeping their
information and their businesses secure
and given the fact that you're joining
us today you probably have some of these
same concerns for your business since
the advent of the cloud we've helped to
address many of these concerns but
there's a lot of traditional security
concerns that you may have as you face
moving towards the cloud so we're going
to be covering the Chrome Enterprise has
a very unique approach to endpoint
security and simplifies device
management and keeps your data safe and
your users protected there we go
so I think we're all aware in in today's
environment that the threat of
sophisticated attacks is constantly on
the increase overall Merrow malware
variants have increased 88 percent since
2017 and the attack vector surfaces have
increased ransomware like wanna cry has
infected over 400,000 machines and 98%
of victims were Windows 7 computers and
as Windows 7 is still out in the
environment they are still vulnerable to
to ransomware and finally phishing
attempts are one of the most common ways
that infections find themselves into
organizations through email users are
deceived to click on to attacks and put
software and their computers and
unwillingly give out information
including their data and user name and
passwords which can be a major security
concern for companies so let's also talk
about the material impact it has
businesses as they try to address these
vulnerabilities so year-over-year
security companies have new software
offerings out in the environment and
security and and companies are
increasingly buying software to help
protect against these threats so the
security market is forecasted to
increase about 9% in the following year
here in 2019 what the the the major
concern though is that the number of
threats is increasing by 27 percent so
while there's an increase in technology
to help mitigate it the it far exceeds
the threats far exceed the ability to
mitigate them and so this is a growing
problem because the amount that you
spend to protect your information and
protect your endpoints may not correlate
to your ability to actually mitigate
those risks and defend from them so as
we see more traditional security
approaches broken there's a lot of
familiar threats that are cataloged by
security companies and security software
and then they're implemented by your
your security teams and organizations IT
administrators to hopefully combat that
security threat that you have in your
environment the fact is though that
increasing the global security budget
shows that a genuine willingness for to
address these threats from companies but
it doesn't mean that it actually
decreases the number of incidents that
organizations have and so the
organization's incrementally funnel more
and more time into patchwork security
systems endpoint protection and putting
out spot fires but they don't have a
holistic approach to fixing these issues
and simply throwing money at it doesn't
actually solve the problem either and
it's time to rethink your endpoint
strategy and this is something that
Google Chrome Enterprise is available
for you to rethink that right so let's
talk about Chrome OS it's built with
security by design it was built like
that when the platform originally
started and isn't like your traditional
endpoint where usually you're layering
on third-party software to protect it
it's a completely different mindset a
completely different mind your thinking
on how to protect your endpoint trusted
applications is an
way to increase your security in your
environment and decrease vulnerabilities
by only publishing secured applications
and applications that are approved by
the organization you reduce the threat
to your business by having unknown
applications in your environment and
finally protection against current
threats and this goes back to like most
organizations they have to update their
computer systems and their software and
their M points constantly to stay
protected against these threats to
combat these you know we we often deploy
different OS Azure other embedded OS is
to help with these security factors
where malware and some of these other
things aren't available by design but
then you're still left as an
administrator still combating these
threats with other third party tools so
now let's look how Chrome Enterprise has
a completely different approach to how
you can keep your business safe Chrome
Enterprise devices and browser Chrome
browser are secured by design they deter
users from falling hostage to harmful
attacks in the event that one does
happen Chrome Enterprise has various
security tools built in to mitigate
those attacks and lessen the ability
that they would have on your ear systems
we have a series of management tools and
a multi-faceted ecosystem of various
products to ensure that you stay safe
within your organization we also offer
24 by 7 support to protect you and your
assets including your people your data
and your customers so now let's talk and
go a little more in depth about the
security by design about Chrome OS and
chrome devices so chrome devices are
built with security from the ground up
and you can see in the representation of
the of the chart here every Chromebook
is built with this same principles in
mind the firmware the OS the
applications and the data and the and
the applications being Chrome OS and
other applications you deploy in your
environment so no matter what hardware
manufacturer you pick whether it's an HP
a Samsung an Acer or Google made
Hardware like this pixel book all these
pieces are within every single Chrome
device that you may purchase as a
customer they all work in
together the the firmware the OS and the
applications and the data are all
updated through one update through your
Chrome OS update and they work in
harmony together and additionally Google
works very closely with the
manufacturers so there is no so only the
hardware works with Chrome OS that's
developed by the manufacturer so finally
let's talk about data encryption it's a
very popular topic that comes up and in
many traditional environments
enterprises are left having to find
third party tools to encrypt their data
not only of their operating systems but
of their user data as well
Chrome OS out of the box protects any
user data with encryption on the device
there is a trusted platform module which
is a tamper proof design that helps
protect the user data on the devices by
encrypting it as the users are working
within their session this tamper proof
system was designed by Google and is
implemented by the OEMs and is available
on every single Chrome device and in
fact encryption is the default on every
Chrome device there is no way to have a
Chrome device that is not encrypted so
let's talk a little bit about preventing
OS tampering and this is another very
unique thing that Google is able to do
with chrome OS that enhances its
security beyond traditional alessa's
verified boot is a manner in which the
Google Hardware along with the firmware
and the OS is able to check against the
known image that is made and provided by
Google that is in that known stable
state as it was originally deployed so
in this in this example here if the OS
was to be tampered with it would not
pass verify boot when it doesn't pass
verify boot the device is not booting
and the data is not available to users
and at that point the device you there
needs to be reimage or wiped so it could
be restored to factory defaults so let's
also talk about Chrome OS and how it
actually reduces your data footprint
Chrome OS devices are unique in which
data is not traditionally stored on an
OS while it does have a file system it
is not traditional like a traditional
file system that can be accessed by
applications and users the file system
is
a lockdown and is not accessible and is
not accessible by the application so it
really reduces the attack vector that
malicious applications would have on the
device additionally by reducing the
actual data the user data in your
company data on the device if the device
is lost you can be assured that company
data isn't on the device because the
data is used in the cloud and is not
stored locally on the device but we can
also know that that that if device if
data is stored on the device it is an
encrypted partition in the user
partition and finally a feature that's
very popular in Chrome OS is what's
called a ephemeral mode which means
every time the user enters and exits ur
session any local data and encash data
is wiped every single time so they have
a clean user session and no data is left
behind there's no data footprint so
regularly patching an update is a very
common administrative tasks of computer
systems and Chrome has a unique update
method for its Chrome devices so every
six weeks Google produces a new version
of Chrome OS and it is available for
Chrome OS devices to be updated too it
is in best practice to keep your Chrome
OS up-to-date using automatic updates
and additionally security patches are
delivered every two to three weeks as
well
we offer what's known as dev beta and
stable channel to our customers so they
can actually be testing the Chrome OS
software ahead of its actual release to
stable branch this gives security
organizations IT administrators an
application owners the ability to test
their applications before it's launched
to stable so if there are security
issues that need to be mitigated with an
application an IT team is able to
discover those early on before chrome is
updated and finally the the most unique
thing about chrome law updates is how
quickly they happen in the background
patching is really a seamless process
where patches happen in the background
it's one patch for your chrome OS update
and that includes your firmware your
your hardware the OS and the application
and that one update happens in the
background and there's nothing more than
a six second reboot or close of the lid
and reopening of Chrome so Google also
offers a lot of other services outside
of the Chromebook
that also help deterred employee
negligence so I think we all know in a
corporate office there is
extracurricular internet browsing and
that can introduce vulnerabilities into
your environment users clicking on
phishing emails or visiting websites
outside their corporate allow lists and
what Google offers is Google Safe
Browsing Safe Browsing prompts users
about malicious sites before they
navigate to them and this is the power
of Google keeping a huge database of
known websites that are malicious or
ransom in nature and prevent users from
going to them and will prompt users if
they go to them and from the
administrative side from an enterprise
management side you have the ability to
block users going to them and this is a
Google product Google service that you
can layer on top of your your Chrome OS
device to make sure any of that extra
browsing doesn't affect your
infrastructure so now let's talk about
some of the various application stores
that Google manages to keep malicious
apps off your devices and can present
users with different aspects and
features of Chrome so there's many
different types of applications that you
can deploy on Chrome OS on Chrome OS you
can use our Google Play Store this is
the Android Market that you're very
similar to using on your Android device
and you can deploy Android applications
to your Chrome OS device you can also
access the Chrome browser which is a
popular way to access web applications
finally the Chrome Web Store these are
extensions that you can install onto
your Chrome browser and your Chrome OS
device and most recently is running
native Linux applications Linux can run
within a container on your Chrome OS
device and you can deploy Linux
applications to them so let's talk about
Sam boxing Sam boxing is something that
is very unique to Google Chrome and to
Chrome OS that is it heart of its
security model Sam boxing is the concept
that all browser tabs applications and
and web apps that you deploy to your
devices are contained within themselves
and they do not have access to the OS
and to other applications this is a
model that makes sure that your
applications cannot access your OS
cannot actually share data and
applications cannot cross talk to one
another and site isolate
on top of this keeps all the processes
within each browser tab separate part of
this methodology is what keeps your
Chrome OS device so secure that even if
you do hit a malicious site that it only
stays within that one sandbox and is not
able to affect other areas of your
chrome device the Chrome Web Store
is a very popular chrome marketplace
where you can download extensions and
get various applications to deploy to
your users from an enterprise management
side you can push those applications out
to your users and users also have the
ability to manually install them Chrome
Web Store applications also have
permissions that they that they will
affect on your Chrome device and as an
administrator you have the ability to
block permissions so certain
applications cannot access certain areas
of your Chrome device such as maybe
block in a USB port and finally other
chrome security measures have been in
place to disable the inline extent the
install of extension so extensions can
only be installed from Google's Chrome
Web Store where machine learning and
artificial intelligence is used to
ensure those applications deploy do not
contain any malware so management of
Chrome devices is a very popular method
to managing the various policies on your
device there's over 200 policies
available in the console and at this
time some of the blacklisting and white
listing of extensions and applications
are widely used by enterprises to pick
and choose applications that they deploy
in their environment whether it be to
users or to devices you also have the
ability to blacklist URLs and prevent
users from accessing sites that you have
forbidden as an organization and finally
the password alert policy is something
that you can employ to ensure that your
users don't use their corporate password
in non corporate authorized websites so
this can ensure that your their
corporate owned passwords do not become
fished or utilized in other areas
outside of the corporate environment so
Android apps on Chromebooks is an
ever-growing
to deploy applications in your on your
chrome devices play protect is a is a a
a proprietary way that Google inspects
the applications within the Android
Market and it scans and removes
applications every single day from the
marketplace ensuring that you're only
deploying known good applications to
your environment additionally as an
enterprise feature as an administrator
you can build a curated list of
applications that your users can then
choose to install and as an
administrator you can on also choose to
deny applications as well that shouldn't
be installed and finally each individual
application may also have individual
specific app policies that you can apply
to that application as well whether it
be configuration or security settings of
the app itself
now let's go over some protection
against current threats and how we can
keep our users and our data safe and
secure so phishing is a very common
attack vector currently and phishing is
the concept that an email is sent to a
user that looks legitimate and is
ultimately getting them to click to
proceed to another website or
application or to download software but
it is not what the user is actually
expecting it is malicious software and
is ultimately trying to either export
rate their data or gain access to their
systems so Google Safe Browsing is one
method you can use to protect yourself
against these threats and at Google we
use what's called a security keys but
essentially a second form factor for
your identity can be another popular
method to protect your users from
phishing so even if they do willingly
give out their password the the attacker
won't have the second form factor
available and finally if the attack
prevails implementing the password alert
policy so both users and administrators
can be aware that a corporate password
has been used on a site that isn't owned
or corporately managed so ransomware is
a little bit different it's designed to
block access to a computer system until
some of money is paid or negotiations
have been required to gain access back
to your system to recover your data the
chrome Bach the Chromebook data model is
completely different and is is really
low on device data footprint meaning
there's no data on a Chromebook really
to hold ransom because the data isn't on
the device
the Chrome OS is a read-only operating
system meaning that you can't install
software to affect the OS to infect it
or install software that may do this
and finally if ransomware did exist for
for Chromebooks the verified boot method
would ensure that it was not able to be
infected and would would not pass
verified boot methods and finally is
Chromebooks don't run traditional
Windows operating systems and
executables making them there for a
inhospitable place to operate within the
ransomware environment so other common
attack vectors are malicious
applications and these are to be
applications that ultimately look to
exfiltrate data from your environment or
from your users and permission based
block blocking is a popular method to
ensure that these applications don't
have access to your data so whether it's
blocking or you are access to URLs or
blocking access to portions of the USB
ports and things of that nature you're
able to to block lists or black
permissions to applications as well and
manage Google Play also then lets you
just curate that list of applications
for your users so your users aren't
using applications that haven't been
approved for by IT and finally if
attacks do happen remember we have the
sandbox environment so any attack only
happens within that contained sandbox or
application environment and doesn't
affect the OS and other applications
running on your Chrome OS device so this
is a very common question we get from
enterprises is their new into into
Chrome OS is why Chromebooks don't
require antivirus or malware software so
one is really again as is Chrome OS was
designed from the ground
but as a secure operating system it is a
read-only operating system and
applications cannot be installed and
they cannot modify the OS therefore
limiting the ability of what antivirus
software would be able to check for
sandboxing isolates applications so they
can only attack within their own
controlled environment it goes a little
bit further that antivirus software
typically wants to be able to scan
entire systems and Chrome OS is not a
scannable system nor would have access
to scan its other applications verified
boot is typically another method to
prevent or tampering of devices and if a
device is tampered with it won't be
bootable and the user would have to wipe
the device in order to regain access to
it I'm wiping any data along with it and
finally is there is the ability as an
administrator to curate and manage your
controlled list of extensions and apps
to your chrome devices further limiting
the attack vector and the applications
that will run in your environment so why
are Chromebook updates so effective I'd
like to say it's because one update does
so many things the chrome update is very
unique in the ability that it updates
your firmware your operating system and
your application with one update there's
not separate updates for patching
applications or patching OS and patching
firmware the update happens in the
background it is seamless to the user
and it is a six second reboot in fact in
many cases users don't realize they've
been updated and finally there are ways
of managing the updates through the
administrative console so you can
selectively choose when updates are
delivered to your users and what devices
receive the updates so Chromebooks are
really a trusted business laptop in
environments right to keeping
enterprises data secure as they move to
the cloud and I'm going to be going over
a couple of customers that are using
Chrome in their environment today so
let's talk about duo security duo
security is a
digital company focused on digital
security and trust compliance and they
were looking for a solution for managing
their data and ensuring that it's secure
no matter where the device is being used
or where the device is deployed so the
the real solution that they were they
were after is that it's secure by design
that they did not have to layer on
third-party software in order to manage
their devices and they also were able to
get a premium device experience using
Google pixel hardware so it offers them
in their words it offered a more
effective endpoint control and security
the extensions and the the webstore
offered a wide array of applications and
services that they could deploy and
manage and they also mentioned that
their premium devices such as the Google
pixel is rival over other competitors
devices and again suitable for both
public facing and internal use cases so
Charles Schwab is another Adam prize
that uses Chromebooks
in addition to Chrome OS customer they
are a highly regulated environment and a
very security minded industry and one of
the reasons that they've chose the
platform is the settings that it
afforded to their administrators in
order to manage the devices Chrome OS
devices and chrome management is a much
more simplistic way of managing endpoint
devices than traditional os's it gives
your administrators more time and
freedom to do work that has higher value
than managing endpoints and of course
you can always learn more by going to
cloud.google.com comm slash Chrome
enterprise security and learn more about
Chrome enterprise and I want to thank
everyone for their time and if you'll
just please stay tuned we're gonna be
going over the live Q&A questions in
just a moment
you
hi everyone this is Jeff Checotah
and I'm back with cloud on air and we're
gonna be going over some customer
questions that we've gotten from our
live audience so let me read the first
question back and then all and then I'll
go into answering it so we have a
question that says how can customers
manage their updates for their fleet of
chrome devices Chromebooks can be
managed through the Chrome Enterprise
administrative console and Google
updates can be managed through that
console you're able to organize your
devices into a series of oh use where
you from there you're able to set
policies that control the updates
including when if you want choose to
have Auto updates or choose to not have
auto updates at Google we call that
pinning it is best practice to remain on
auto updates obviously for best security
reasons and application performance but
as an administrator you do have the
ability to pause those updates as well
there's also a number of other settings
that allow you to stagger the updates
and also control as we mentioned the dev
beta and stable Channel as well out to
your fleet so there's lots of options to
controlling those updates out to your
environment let me go to question number
two are the security benefits mentioned
in this deck available on all chrome
devices with all manufacturers it's a
great question so Chrome OS is is an
operating system made by Google that is
placed on manufacturer Hardware the
manufacturer hardware is negotiated with
Google and contains all the proprietary
components like we mentioned the TPM
module met tamper proof resistant
firmware inside of every single Chrome
device so whether you pick a Chromebook
or a chrome box or other chrome form
factors and and Hardware independent
whether it is Google made Hardware by
another major OAM they all contain those
same underlying security benefits that
you receive and the operating system is
authored by Google for all those same
devices so we have another question here
this question is asking about G suite so
G suite is a popular series of
applications including email Docs sheets
and calendar so it says do I need to be
a G suite customer to
all the benefits of Chrome Enterprise I
would know you do not need to be a G
suite customer to get the benefits of
Chrome enterprises we have lots of
enterprises that are on traditional
productivity applications and are not G
suite customers and are very successful
using Chrome OS variable to deploy their
applications through the cloud console
and manage them in just a similar manner
but simpler than their traditional
Windows devices and their applications
can also be deployed virtually right if
there are dependencies on Windows
applications and that goes into our next
question asking how will we run PC
applications on a Chromebook so PC
applications or executable applications
exe s do not run natively on a
Chromebook what organizations typically
do is virtualize applications and
deliver them to their Chromebook so many
there's many popular virtualization
platforms Google has partnerships with
Citrix and VMware to deliver those
virtual applications onto your
Chromebook but we work with many other
virtualization platforms that are
deployed on the Chromebook as well so
let me go on to our next question so
what are common applications customers
deploy to their end users this is a very
good question also very broad but
there's a series of applications that
I'd say are very common to deploy within
on a Chromebook some of the most popular
applications I think are ones that
organizations use daily such as video
conferencing and teleconferencing
systems such as web bags and zoom and
Google Hangouts but other applications
such as Android applications are also
very popular to deploy including
products by Cisco and Palo Alto and
other networking applications that they
may use and other productivity software
such as Microsoft Office as well as
Google Google G suite and again all
those applications can be deployed
through the management console and are
deployed through the cloud console and
they're pushed to the devices so let me
so we have another question here this is
a little more security oriented about
can we explain a little bit more about
what a ephemeral mode is so we mentioned
in the deck about a unique feature
security feature called a femoral mode a
thermal mode is unique to Chrome OS and
it gives it the ability that every time
we user enters and exits our session
that all the local data within their
profile is wiped so whether it's
downloaded content that they've put in
their downloads folder cache data
passwords anything that may have been
saved during their user session is white
on the on the exit of their session and
every new session created is a blank
profile and no data is stored or
captured and is wiped clean every time
this is as we referred to back in the
deck keeping a low data footprint so
it's a very popular method for
organizations to employ a ephemeral mode
because if they can be ensured that
there is no data left behind on the
device and our last question here is a
little bit on networking and security
tools what networking and security tools
are available for Chromebooks most of
the major manufacturers of networking
applications provide applications at
both in the webstore the Chrome Web
Store and on the Android Market for
networking applications so whether it's
VPN applications or proxy applications
most of the major manufacturers are
available within the Google Web Store
and on the Android Play Store I'd say
the more popular ones are obviously
Cisco and Palo Alto but many others
exist from the other network providers
as well so I think that wraps up our
questions that we've gotten from our
audience I just want to thank everyone
for tuning in and to please visit cloud
on-air to discover more content from
Google cloud experts thank you very much
you
you